das kann ich sagen ich werde in der
nächsten folge ich mache jetzt kann ich
werde in der nächsten folge versuchen
was wirst du diese folge machen
naja ich gehen eine statue ist schon
okay kommt
nein ich wollte eigentlich noch exil
diamanten suchen lexika lizenzen weil
ich brauche noch 46 ik lassen damit ich
mir entweder ist die brüstung des geldes
zu machen können machen kann
und da habe ich letzte folge auf twitter
gefragt was ihr denn haben wollt was mir
da mache danke an die shoah ja viele
antworten sag ich jetzt einfach mal so
ich hab sonne nicht geguckt aber ich sag
einfach mal und da will ich jetzt ganz
kurz nach gucken was die leute denn
meinen was ich machen soll
in der zwischenzeit bist du hier der
alleinunterhalter dass der falter ich
mag das die ganze zeit reden kann eine
hälfte hälfte scales gales gay games gay
lief danach scale
ich bin ja soo scale scale
okay ganz klar eigentlich scale ok allem
einsammeln des geldes zu machen wenn ich
mir wahrscheinlich eine rüstung machen
und danach dann die tief am ohr
da müssen wir dann einfach nochmal
mexikaner suche gehen diese skelette
irgendwas heiligkeit gefallen oder nicht
doch stoppen
naja ich in ordnung und dann werde ich
mir die rüstung ich weiß nicht wie teuer
kostet einmal sollte einmal sollte das
ich weiß nicht wie viele level aber man
schafft es vielleicht wenn man nur so 30
hast du schaffst es nicht für alle
rüstungsteile vielleicht zehn oder sogar
schon von meyer das voll schwer in der
kritik
aber es ist irgendwie ich muss dir
erstmal auch stellen keine ahnung oder
muss ja mit geschossen werden das für
ein ding jetzt hier
jft kräftig haben wind medaillon
betrachtet das auf das sich auf wenn er
gegen kommen werden werden denn du
abgeschossen wird von einer person echt
ich muss dich abschließen sagt bartel
gesehen online ist ja ewig du musst du
mir kommen mehr oder weniger jetzt
leider kann ich ja sowieso ein skelett
abschließen einfach ich glaub ich weiß
nicht ich kann auch sein du musst auf
jeden fall von feiern getroffen werden
ok zustand kannst du damit diese laut
putz machen
ja das möchte ich mache meine sache ist
aber wenn du die cloud fuß hast dann
hast du die rüstung halt nicht komplett
egal wie ich möchte nicht geklappt
meinte kohl ausmachen
was kann ich möchte die wirbelwind boots
machen ja egal dass in trotzdem fuhr er
dann seine rüstung hat nicht komplett
dass keine verzauberung
euro um ein grad warte irgendwer hier
noch ein ding ich laufe einfach meiner
stadt rum irgendwo sind bestimmt
irgendwelche merck wenn leute die
schießen aber irgendwie ja ich bin schon
so lange nicht mehr gestorben das so
heftig ich auch dass ich auch ich weiß
auch nicht wie das möglich ist aber ist
läuft im moment bei mir schon ewig nicht
mehr gestorben
nicht mal mehr fast alltag einfach schön
welches schild hätte ich denn und das
obwohl ich durch lava geschwommen bin
ich bin so ein lava wasser von hoch
geschwommen benutzt du eigentlich
irgendwann mal ein schild ja gerade
nicht abgehört sonnenschein in das dort
aber mir darfst du nicht mit mir das
nicht vertrauen gehört wenn man giants
ort hat dann das gleiche funktion wie
ein schwert erwin blog wien weiß
bescheid
ich habe von living legend spot ist
damit kann ich auch blocken ja ich
glaube halt auch rim something big macs
am tag
die 3
klaus gall tänzler
die sonne geht obwohl wie geil das
aussieht storagecraft erstmalig wind
keine skelett ist das zum kotzen alter
ernste nacht herum gewandert jetzt muss
ich zu dir kommt damit du mich
abschließt damit meint wind amulett ging
mir abgeschaut eingestimmt und alles
krieg dann hat mein lieber mann ist kann
ich sagen ich auch schon die ganze zeit
hier oben und ich kenne kein ja ein
choral schon abgegrast
oh mein gott das ein blaues leinwand
gespannt
ich geh jetzt mal ohne scheiß höhle 100
welches man als euch doch die frist
immer mehr frust und wenn ich jetzt
richtig richtig schnell unterwegs dann
könnte ich viel schneller neue hektar
lizenzen rand kommt aber der krieg ist
dies keine rüstung glaube ich besser
mann
das ist allen dreien entscheide nicht
ich sondern offensichtlich hat die scale
up scale armer hellfire resistance der
firma waterfalls ab ins final sales of
course you keep swinging sind nicht
gesetztes doch zum abstützen kotzen
alter meine fresse halten
hier war jedoch das habe ich in seiner
folge gesehen naja okay dass da
gestorben vielleicht von mir jedoch war
drin und hat den turm einfach alleine
gemacht aber das kann ich auch
mittlerweile mit meiner rüstung
ich habe schon ganz viele richtungen
allein at&t alleine gemacht ja und da
findet man manchmal so gute essenzen
drin aber ja eben durch seine antwort
auf meine frage mich wie gut mir
mittlerweile egal ich habe einfach ein
paar filme gemacht und dafür jetzt auch
aber ist er gleich am besten wenn ich
mir so ein pelikan es werde euch am
besten wenn ich mir so ich fühle mich
echt weh doch so einer einsamen insel
ihr folge ist er gleich am besten auto
es wäre am besten wenn ich wirklich
irgendwie sexy carl sachen finden würde
damit ich danach dann eben mit gelber
und so wenn ich da nicht mehr sterben
kann quasi mehr oder weniger kann man
damit eigentlich nicht sterben dann gehe
ich damit einfach in einen turm und box
als um das ist mein plan
stoppst du alles um nicht schon alles um
roberto man ja wohl los
die braut kam kaka mit camelia lala
johann nicht sein jetzt ist hier ein
ozean
becker ich erschieße mich wirklich
abläuft bei ihm ja wohl schießen gab ja
wohl das wird aufgeladen ich mein gott
ich bin eben ein gefallen ich bin über
einen gefallen aber das ist glaube ich
nicht wir hatten schiff jetzt wird
geboxt jungs war erstmals essen
geschnappt gefunden leicht beim ja es
ist aufgeladen
ich kann sogar noch ein zweites aufladen
jawohl alter ok meine lieben freunde
mein erster richtiger fight
ich habe aber keinen goldenen apfel oder
etwas verdammt oder ist noch ein schiff
solcher große das kleinen erstes gerufen
und war direkt ans eingemachte wenn
jetzt sterbe mir am arsch du war richtig
weit weg da muss erst mal meinen denkt
finden ja legal macht voll spaß
ich lass mir einfach abschießen und das
skelett hat auch spaß niedermähte like
that gets tough drive select mit needs
to be charged lago maggiore die
glättungslinie gina kalt
ich brauche übrigens diese trichter hier
nachher für das mit den seelen und so
nicht damit jetzt denkt von luca
donnerstag mit da muss ich mich nicht
mehr kräften desto blöd mich zu treffen
der [ __ ] muss zu mir kommen aber ich
glaube ich bin noch zu billig zu treffen
das schafft das schon da ist nur essen
also macht er weniger schaden als du von
daher läuft wobei das natürlich fragt
ich komme ja auch wenig schaden ich muss
mich muss ein großes tief in den spaß
die darstellen soll jetzt ist ja ja
das ist jedes mal ein investor im baltic
i have nothing ärzte sind alles nur
erstens sachen hier heißen kann wovon
specht noch ein ding ist werde es kein
geld aufladen
ich bin einem schiff drin und ich hab
mich gleich verlaufen weil jetzt überall
nur essen jetzt das sieht gut aus hier
herrscht ein problem
ich bin im schiff aber hier sind keine
monster oder gegner oder irgend etwas in
die richtung alter spaß die krise kaum
noch mein gott da kommt er kommt genau
hänge aber überall auf bilder und
gemälde und aber gar keine sportler hier
ist einfach nichts wie ist das schön mir
gefällt das einfach nicht so - ohne gott
noch allerdings wehrt sich läuft hart
zuerst war ich noch ein einziges
weiteres ding und das auch schon noch
zur hälfte voll oder fast zum drittel
naja viertel sah liebe skelett ich ziehe
immer auf dich ich würde sagen mach
lieber schnell weil sonst bist du gleich
abgeschossen
es kann nicht sein dass mit der was mit
dem kind passiert altar dato 230 jahr
mit einem schuss altar ok oh yeah comic
mibrag mbh wo es hat ja geklappt federn
also beinahe jetzt auf das nächste
schiff das kann doch nicht sein alter
aber direkt einer hier
ich habe zwei drittel der kanone gehört
eine kanone der mit einer kanone auf
mich geschossen
nach oben bauen
abschießen kann jetzt wirklich eine
kanone ist einfach eine kanone eine
richtige kanonen die man sieht ja du
meinst jetzt piratenkapitän afrikaner
heißt der last eines der revolver das
habe ich auch okay da unten sich eine
menge erfahrung ich habe auch mit dem
rasen keine play das tier und nachbar
für unterwasser sieht bei dir nix mit
dem schluss dass das dafür einer
gelösten beleuchten dabei die man nicht
dass jetzt trinke ich mal vogelschießen
ok bedeuten vogelschießen kam im februar
findet jeder wenig sehen welche items
ich habe vor gekühlten jedoch nicht
ich krieg die krise hier ist überall nur
essen drin ist immer der eurokraten
schiff nähert ist die erfahrung gemacht
aber egal wessen brot das ist gut lasst
mich erst im kopf meiner man hessen drin
ist und da hinten glaube ich habe ich
etwas gesehen und zwar einen turm aber
ich denke aber doch schon geblutet
das ist doof seiner umgebung wird alles
schon genug obwohl jedoch nicht jetzt
jedoch relativ hoch aus beide stützen
ja aber nicht komplett zusammen ich mal
nur die hälfte sagt ja aber jetzt nichts
und er ist ein piratenschiff zwischen
den beiden türmen mein gott was mach ich
auch noch nicht gesehen als er sich mega
ethisch aus um ein boot ist kaputt
gegangen
fail ja ich hab ich ein bisschen was von
dem stuff er reingelegt ich nicht
brauche ich ja nicht mehr weil ganze
zeit dabei stehe ich nicht so richtig
viele piraten richtig viele piraten sind
ihr wichtig pirat nicht die finma da
sind richtig richtig viele spinnen und
die sind locker 30 millionen locker 30
millionen und die habe mich verzaubert
habe ich mit ihnen was verzaubert meine
ganze bildschirm flimmert aber ich hatte
ein bisschen angst
da ist das auf jeden hier sind hier ist
alles möglich unseren er sein rezept
weiter gucken und mein gott alter ja
gerade wichtige dinge zu tun von
geschrei nicht so ich muss mir kannst
andré an
ich habe angst ich habe richtig angst
käsehaus station 200
okay okay als begeht der epische
kampeter seit dieser spenden hier ein
okay und ich betrete einfach alle ich
würde einfach alle
mein gott oh mein gott mein gott oh mein
gott oh mein gott ich habe ein bisschen
angst ich ein bisschen angst ich hab ich
glaube ich brauche ich jetzt erstmal
hier ein gemacht hat und dann
regeneriere ich mich erst mal kurz
werden können er wundert sich keine
blöcke kaputt aus als in friedberg eine
krippe hier könnte eigentlich
theoretisch könnten nicht reinkommen
hier kommt nichts gesagt
jetzt nehme ich erst mal ein peg peg
raus wenn er gut organisiert hier und
packt erstmal die wichtigen sachen rein
die werte noch mal gebrauchen könnte das
mindestens pompösen ist in swat tal ist
es
fressen hervor jetzt nicht gold mein
gott ich habe wirbelwind puls neben den
king alter so da ich bin jetzt erstmal
runter springen will nicht weg packen
damit dass hier und den respekt hier
rein was ich nicht brauche ich bin voll
schnell alter jetzt kann ich mir auch
nichts mehr
aber ich weiß nie ist das jetzt
schneller als die frist um oder ist das
genauso schnell wie sie fällt nur ist es
sogar langsamer als die fristen ist es
langsamer glaube ich es war voll schwer
zu machen halben sky die kollektion
alles ganz nett zum schneller laufen auf
jeden fall so hier habe ich ein paar
items und jetzt werde ich da richtig
randale machen
obwohl ich traue mich irgendwie ich trau
mich nicht erfasst
das war der der mit der dümmste blog den
ich auf jeden fall bisher lang
eingestellt
18 minuten aber ich kann nicht aufhören
ich bin gerade okay ich kann aufhören
damit sagen damit man auch noch platz ok
ich muss doch verzaubern
ich hoffe dir 18 stimmen mich verarscht
dich gerade
ja ich habe angst
diese ganzen boxwelt ist halt einfach
nicht aufgekommen einfach unendlich
viele rein diese erste etage ist mega
schlimm hier bei diesem thema trauer
ich weiß gar nicht wie ich da gleich ein
kommen soll
die meisten lust richtig scheiße gerade
ich habe hier nur noch hälfte der leben
sehe ich gerade alter ich will weg hier
und die sind überall skelette und so was
alles ich kann hier quasi gar nicht weg
ich hab so angst mein gott egal werde
ich überleben da ist ein alten skeletts
und pumpkin auf die welt jetzt erst mal
direkt abschließen
warum kann ich ja schwerlich reparieren
verstehe ich nicht man schon ein gottes
bekommen habe was du in den dingen das
war ein ganz normaler bogen die ich
benutze mein gott ich bin so schlecht
gerade das kann ich sagen ich werde in
der nächsten folge ich mache jetzt
gerade ich werde in der nächsten folge
versuchen um einfach scheiße scheiße
mann das ist das toben ist eben wie
aufgegangen da kommt jetzt alle rein
junge [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] halbes
herz um ein gotteshaus herzlich halbes
herz halbes herzen gottes gestellt ob
jetzt generiert sich wie das generiert
sich wieder während vergiftet lena ich
komme nicht aus muss mich irgendwie
nächsten folge hieraus werden erklären
kann nicht sein
hier sind überall mops ich muss mir den
blick nach draußen bahnen oder irgendwie
sowas
das kann nicht sein
einmal hätten die folge wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal wieder meine lieben
freunde
ich hoffe ich komme irgendwie leben
draus wir haben einen kanal machen soll
ich hätte dich luca nicht luca relativ
leicht nächste folge jene zuschauer
einig war massiv